call me hoops all right i'm
max actually i kind of like willow can i
be willow
you be willow wade
wade you know who you are of these two
and that's not it
no he's a basketball player his name is
hoops all right that's fair enough
why is it inverted ah what fresh hell is
this
inverted my x-axis on my mouse
is inverted why
why why would that be on by default oh
okay game plan figure out where i am
okay i'm fine
probably what squished huh i think that
was my menu
do you guys have dialogue talking right
now oh yeah yeah definitely
what what kind of horror show this is my
whole
box is this i don't know this is not
comfortable to look at this that's
always meant for me there are only four
characters just like
there's five holes so someone's here
maybe the antagonist was in this box
the antagonist hit v to open your hot
pouch
ah my hot pouch this does look hot oh if
you look up it's very pretty
yeah this is this is cool oh that's
beautiful
that's huge
haha bloody pulp hey guys i got a
pebblet
what oh it's a whacking pebblet oh my
god i might whack you
all right okay oh threaten me with a
good time
apparently the wait so is this a
survival crafting game
yeah maybe yeah like i would have known
that well i thought you would have it i
was like yeah
who's fighting who's fighting an aphid
oh
is it you apparently it was me i was
fighting an aphid
oh it's so cute oh i could just oh you
can see the
house oh the laser this is honey i
shrunk the kids
guys i made a spit here a what
holy [ __ ] that is a laser yeah look at
that
that's right i'm collecting all the sap
on this stick all right
as leader of this expedition i don't
know if anyone elected you to be a
leader
it's not about elections climb the stick
to the baseball
i will not that's not what the leader
has said
the leader ooh i'm gonna go with the
real leader here
the leader has found the science
equipment
hello later analyze this rock
good rock look look at that i could do
that
wow that's a good rock i have this rock
and some sap
yeah that's great
good job there friend uh that's leader
friend
do you yeah respect our leader you
douche you can just call me leader you
don't have to
dare do you speak the leader that way
non-leader mark no i mean that's not my
name
at all i don't like being friendly with
the lower class skus that work for me
i like them to refer to me with respect
and just call me leader
i'm we're not friends in this situation
i'm the leader listen wade my leader how
do i make woven fiber
um oh requires workbench oh cool
hey mark did you find a workbench that
the leader can use our
leader is already using it leader is
already uh no he's out here
he's out here with me i'm pretty sure
okay yeah i'm over here
um excellent anyway i'm already
independent
along the way as the leader i'm going to
elect bob to be the leader
because he's further ahead he ran
further ahead to catch up to you so
therefore i feel like he's a better
leader
than me newly appointed leader
well you know what uh co-leader i
appreciate you
i appreciate you saying that and uh i oh
good the worker is out there
killing bugs i've done it oh grass thank
you for the pleasure
i have a blade of grass i'm going
to huck this at you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's not very nice i'm analyzing sap
oh now i can make a pebblet x oh we can
make a workbench now
i already made a pebblet axe i am
pioneering technology that you couldn't
possibly understand did i make two
pebblet axes accidentally i'm so
confused
i am so sorry oh hey some grass planks
thank you i am so strong i'm lifting
five of these all right let's you know
let's just agree to disagree on this and
let's but let's work together
as a team i'm gonna later i'm gonna go
ahead and say that's our strategy
all right fair enough think of whatever
title you want
we all know who's in charge
yeah it's me good let's work together
hey look an aunt
that can't be good he's pretty big he's
over here i think
they're fine oh hey look a fly that
can't be good
oh you're you're you're a little you're
adorable how come
hawk
how did you do that that seemed
unnecessarily uh violent
so this ah that really seemed to injure
you sir
are we my health is seemingly low um
are we trying to build a base i'm i'm
actually yeah i think we're trying to
build a base i think that's what's going
on here
i do believe i looked are there actually
i thought i i
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] my ex
i could build a hammer no with woven
fiber need the woven fibers
uh yeah you can get fiber from picking
up the reeds on the ground and then
fiber yeah yeah i think i'll make a
hammer if good let's head up
to what do i need to make a hammer let's
if one of us researches something
something does
it give it to everybody yes okay cool
the research i think so yeah okay cool
good i have
nat fuzz and raw nat meat i killed a net
did it die
screaming it died squishing good
maybe there's ants killing it
do we need a spear to fight it all right
never mind
i killed the gnat but the ants the ants
what about the ants
there were many ants i don't even see an
ant
all right so how do we build like base
stuff base building wow
we probably haven't researched it yet
i'm going to clear some space around
this um
science thing and i'm guessing that's a
good place to start
okay yeah so that'll be like our base
yeah
i'm real tuckered guys oh do we have an
energy bar i see health
oh i'm thirst i need to drink something
apparently yeah uh mushroom
40 centimeters centimeters scott the
scale of this is actually really cool
okay there are mushrooms don't give
water i don't think uh there must be
there's water on the underside of some
of the blades of grass i like to slurp
some
some droplets of water up there oh i see
it's got to be like
nice find bob you're a great leader this
is adorable
can i just say this but that's really
pleasant it's
it's literally just a survival crafty
game but also it's adorable so i don't
care hey there's an ant here looking at
me is that bad
hey he's not attacking me he looked at
me and left i think we should probably
not mess with the ants they seem like
badass
maybe not oh you're way up on the tippy
top i'm on a blade
i can see i'm uh i just walled my own
bit
let's make the house north or or the the
pole
that's at their the laser that's at the
house that'll be like north
to the south uh there's a shed there's
three lasers uh there's a rake that'll
lead
up to the house that i think will let
you get up there it's like a weather
balloon
there's so much stuff oh
hey hey we're friends we're friends
yeah definitely don't attack the ants
because if they've got a colony that's
going to be a big problem
oh what's this what is dry
how do we make that put it in the sun
i might have fallen into a puddle of
piss i'm thirsty
hey does anyone have some sap yes
oh god i i that was piss uh
why why i drank it
whoa what is this i'm analyzing the
grass
oh okay okay i thought we didn't analyze
grass yet oh
the plank yeah i found a tic tac
container oh you can make
triangle wall okay oh sorry no good
stuff
ice caps acorn shovel and eye patch
oh eye patch yeah i've got i got those
hopefully that's just cosmetic and not
because we're gonna have eye injuries
spider oh no oh no
[Music]
oh no i have everything i i can craft a
workbench if i just pick up some grass
planks did we
unlock like the building buildings uh we
have walls doors
and that's it for base building but for
utilities i can craft a workbench right
now
oh i see okay mark's figuring it out too
so you place the things down and then
you have to bring the resources
and construct them but i was i was gonna
no you're fine you're fine i was gonna
tell you guys about it once i
did it and i was gonna be like i
discovered something and then
but you didn't let me say it so it's
like you said it not me
it was a good discovery right right we
all discover things in our own way
well but in this way i was sure sure i
had i was going to be like guys i made
this a
house as your leader i'm happy to give
you credit
that's very kind of your leader bob
thank you the eye patch apparently gives
plus attack
that doesn't make sense are you guys
carrying anything we haven't analyzed
no not last time i checked
nope i got nothing oh my god this door
hates
existing it is so okay no door on this
not gonna have a door a door is no fun
was it the place that you put the door
oh it's because that thing is like
clipping through it isn't it yeah try to
place a door there it it won't i want
to i want to do it
come on baby very upset baby
did you guys go into the computer case
over here
computer case hey leader bob uh hey look
at this this is interesting
i'm almost dead hang on wait for me all
right oh i found that before
ah our left leg man oh no wait that's
that's not what i found never mind
that's something else
i don't uh i don't think this is doing
anything maybe it's just a place to look
at but
no it's got to be something stab it
hit it so why did you get in the way of
where i was
i pushed a button on the mysterious
machine i knew stabbing it will work
that's why i'm second in command
everyone come up here
okay i pushed the target button and now
it's doing stuff
oh oh oh can you push the button the
shrink-o-matic
do i have to hit it you have to eat it
if it doesn't give you a prompt i don't
know if it's going to work
it doesn't give me a prompt maybe it's
not dialed in there's a knob that says
science it's all the way on
off it needs to be up to max oh [ __ ] we
got to turn that
crank the science up get the hey you
knocked me off
p2 is fl is full p3 is flashing p1 is
off
okay maybe that's the problem
something's obstructing oh that blade of
grass is obstructing that
and then the other ones oh okay and that
laser is just kind of flashing so we
have to fix that laser
yeah that one no good okay this one's
good
okay what happens if i step in front of
the laser if i
look directly at it and begging me
should we go towards that laser and see
what the deal is
yeah i guess yeah i've almost made it to
the
laser oh uh yeah we're on our way to
help
were you but we all agreed oh
this looks like a job for the leader or
the second in command
or whatever you are do i keep dropping
spears i swear i
make spears and then they go away where
does the spear go when you make it
uh that's a great question i don't know
i'm
dead oh god you died the mites
wait the mic was attacking wade attacked
me
i start attacking me too and i'm owning
them like no
wade attacks me i'm helping wade
mark wade hate me i swear
to you i saw we had to get rid of the
monsters first
i saw leader are you going to do
anything about the betrayal that i just
suffered at the hands of
ah trail the betrayal that i suffered he
come help me you do ungrateful followers
i am on the way captain it's dark
it's really dark in that hole i don't
like that do we have any sap
i got more set we should make a torch
with some sap did the laser
fix itself no
i can see where the laser needs to be
fixed um uh-oh
um chop down the grass i'm on chop down
the grass i'm on please
please where are you i'm up above
i'm on a blade of grass i fell down but
i didn't follow all the way
please 20 seconds i want sweet life
nothing more than life i am floating
how'd you get up there what is happening
when i said that i was on the way i
really wasn't on the way because i was
mad because
you weren't doing anything about wade
but now that this is my last moments
i want to say you forgive me i don't i
curse him
with the last of my breath careful bob i
don't want you to get hurt you're
already
i wait you suck
he dropped some grass chunks when he
died i kicked the thimble
there's quit and then there's super quit
oh you can't respawn
no i can respawn i'm fine uh the laser
is still kind of flickering
yeah you falling on the blade of grass
did not seem to fix it
all right listen wade we need to have a
talk
because you're i i did nothing to you
and you're just being mean i'm just
carrying out our leader's orders
his orders were to be mean to me is that
what it was
bob was that your orders yeah you caught
me
all right fair enough as long as we're
all the same hey uh hammerman
i think you know what we need to do oh
it's dark in this hole
yeah that's why you got to follow the
leader with the torch i died i came back
i'm
trying my best guys are you giving it
are you giving it a full hold wade you
gotta fully do that
let a real man do this let me a real man
show you how to hold it same for there
we go
all right onward all i want is some
recognition guys that's that's all i've
ever wanted
yeah get back i recognize you thank you
thank you thank you
we might go and break this because i
feel like this might be a rare material
never mind i can't see i can't pick that
thing i think we need to pick ax
like we would have to have a pickup or a
shovel shovel yeah something like that
that's a craftable uh we can make a
shovel if we have any acorn shells i can
make a shell i don't have that
i have mold
okay i don't have any acorn shells do
you
russian bros and mark no no no no no
would you like to come back down here
after we get a shovel then wait what's a
scab
what the hell i discovered yeah i can't
pick that thing there's something in the
ground what
what is that what
something's digging in the dirt yeah we
know uh it's fine
no need to be such a baby wade
oh the objective says investigate the
machine further
oh it's pretty oh i'm hungry
that was a sad hungry we beat the game
already pretty sure we beat the game
yeah we beat the game
guys i am most hungry my friends all
right
i'm gonna i'm gonna wait to eat until i
get back and make a roasting spit and
see what that does for us
all right sounds good man is the
exclamation point like our home
thing no that's the machine which is now
working right here
uh get on the thing i think we're gonna
we win oh wait
did we do it yeah we did it this is it
on my way
maybe we should just one at a time just
to see what kind of happens all right
cool three two one
what uh
all right that's it that's the game
thanks for watching guys all right
[Music]
oh no well that can't be good
huh all right well that sounds like oh
my god that ladybug
oh no i think juicy juicy delicious bug
that's what i'm thinking guys i'm real
thirsty uh do we have anything
droplets i bet this is she wants to see
a ladybug would cough up some juice
leader do i have authorization to attack
this ladybug
do it right the eyes co-authorization
group it's
glowing red eyes don't come again
uh mark did you um did you make the
ladybug dude the ladybug is the scariest
thing
don't attack a ladybug don't look at it
it's terrifying dude you really pissed
it off
anyway that health bar that is a dark
souls boss health bar that is
that is terrifying oh don't i've fallen
oh do you want me to get you up
okay you don't mind i was i was waiting
for it to de-aggro on you uh
is it mad at me it was all it was making
lots of dodge a [ __ ]
no it's fine
oh uh look out
oh it's fine it's okay hi ladybug
communicating oh it's inside of me i
don't like that okay
beautiful how do we get back to camp
we're it's right over here that doesn't
mean very much oh there you are
we're on our way all right number one
what is this
raw science dew collector ooh
that sounds like a good crafting thing
to do oh yeah we definitely need some of
that we need
things we need weed stems and quartzite
which we have and spider cells which we
don't have i would imagine
there's a uh a shitty structure here
made of leaves and grass
you know what it's very nice and i'm
gonna put the cooking apparatus inside
of it because it's such a nice little
structure thank you
thank you bob thank you the your leader
approves
thank you that means the world to me all
right we have a cooking structure my
dudes
we do yeah i'll go get you some food bob
wait if you're hungry i have food for
you come here
i'm uh never mind i ate it i'm quite
wrong
apparently if you put it in your hot bar
and then try and put it in your hand you
just immediately eat it that's my bad
that's my bad
i'm good i almost attacked the ant hi
aunt
i bet that ant's got some good meat on
it i would imagine
we really need one of them dew
collectors yeah what do we need
take stuff we definitely don't have are
you sure about six
six weed stems eight quart sites which
we do have and
five spider silks which we do not have i
will brave the spider's nest
for you bob there we go leadership
inspires me to action uh well okay
i will make you proud care just
uh be chill i drank pee again but it's
cool
i'm in the middle of the forest at night
what is that
i found something
[Music]
oh
that seems like a bad place mark if i
had to guess oh
that's a big deal mark are you finding
friends
yeah friends uh found a big spider but
bob you wanted spider silk i will get we
always
desperately need the spider silk
definitely risk your life for that i
know
i know all kinds of good stuff to make
with spider silk okay
i've got you i need to find its nest
okay i don't know where the spider's
nest is
i don't think they call it a nest but
i'm not finding either
oh my god guys i found a raw science is
that the
pink glowy yeah i just found some of
that too
oh my god there's a tic tac box what the
hell
there are trail markers is a thing we
can craft i wonder if that
like means something uh i found a
swirling purple vortex of energy
[Music]
[Music]
i'm uh oh i've
found something requires a higher tier
tool
there's a thing of mint here but you
need a tier two hammer how in the hell
i found uh something
oh is it good it's a lab
looks like a science lab guys the lean
too
the thing it keeps telling us to build
would allow us to sleep through the
night
oh that's probably useful yeah but
there's so much cool stuff to explore at
night
apparently probably true but we also set
our spawn point
all right you know what i'm not going to
explore this without you guys it seems
like
important stuff i'm going to come back
because it's scary in their spiders and
i didn't get any spider silk bob but i'm
nervous that i will be okay it's okay i
still love you
all right the lean i'm gonna put lean
twos up inside of here
i've got my own to place you can place
one for mark if you want please i'll put
marks over here
put it next to your lean two so we can
lean
together do you have like a flashing red
light in the bottom left underneath your
food and drink
yes what does that flashing indicate who
knows
guys i made it back hey i'm alive
i'm gonna hit the sack where's mine
oh you guys are cuddled up together oh
you guys are
oh what are we are we sleeping yeah
i just have to wait for others stay
close to the rest point well i wanted to
lay next to bobber
yeah we know wait wade's not gonna allow
this to happen
oh let's just let's just sleep okay
we're all basically touching tootsies
worst case here
all right i'll sleep in listen leader
mark
what do you allow us to sleep
sleep oh sorry i didn't know i had to
press sleep
hey oh i have the blinking red light now
that's
uh not good i don't i don't do nothing
hunger
blinking all right so if you if you have
food stuff gib
i have many many many mushrooms
drop that's only one
this is annoying how many mush you got
bro
i have many mush meat does spoil fast so
if you ever get any meat you want to
cook and eat that
apparently if you hit grass that one of
those little green aphids climb up it
knocks it down and you can crush it and
take its meat
oh delicious all right i'm bringing you
some oh apparently you don't cook
mushrooms
never mind i'm an [ __ ] hey mark you
are your mushrooms back
uh no i have acorn pieces
oh you have acorn pieces yeah do you
want them oh we needed those for
something right yeah yeah we need some
of that for some of the construction
stuff
okay do you need to science it oh yeah i
will say
just oh did you get a cap did you get a
cab
yeah yeah oh hell yeah bro yeah yeah
yeah dude i got all this stuff oh
it's gone all right we're good we're
good oh kill kill
meat delicious meat in here whoa
the mushroom on the ground attracted the
weevils mushroom
wow there's another one oh you can also
cook three things at a time guys we got
a whole
spit roast of weevil meats
okay we don't need this many because it
does expire or whatever
but like i'm not gonna eat yet so i'm
gonna need to eat there's there's some
roasts on the spit take one
one of those weevil roasts is like most
of your most of your hunger
what happens if you eat a spoiled i
would imagine you bore
oh the thirst the amount of thirst i
feel how do i get you
you gotta just whack the grass it's on
it falls down and you slurp it up right
off the dirt
give me that wait the surface tension
did you steal
the wha wait wait wait what
it must have uh evaporated
you're just an [ __ ] what no where'd
it go
did mark chop one down and you straight
up stole it
i was jumping at it and pressing e and i
didn't know he was going to chop that
same one
and then it must have evaporated you're
just
a jerk sap respawns on the tr on the
stickies yeah i just got some more sap
i'm not letting this go
you're gonna have to let it go yeah well
you need a snickers bar or something no
i need
water spawns on the leaves if you chop
down one of the grasses it'll drop down
so you can reach it how did you learn
that
common sense his great leader taught him
interesting
i'm gonna talk about i'm
this spider's leg is really stupid got
it poked in the butt i've hooked it in
the butt
i'm running away now oh god analyze
i found out how to make acorn chest
plates and leg plates mark where'd you
get an acorn acorns are the shiz
dude i was on an adventure and
do you wish you knew i do wish i knew
i'm assuming the direction of the giant
acorn tree
yes that is an acorn tree i fell in a
hole boy i wish i could find
water mark are you still on about that
to be a little more proactive
i think everyone else found their own
water hey you discovered weed stuff i
think that you guys are working against
me
i think that this is a conspiracy to
always
put me down even if i make a good
contribution it's always just
boo to me you know where's the
friendship
bob and i are working great together i
don't know where where's the friend
like hey mark did you make that spider
silk you promised me
where's the friendship i need
water mark there's water everywhere hey
mark do you know how you fell from a
high point and
died come here i got a gift for you
no water i found it oh my goodness that
took oh my
god do you find extra water i need some
water yeah mark don't hug it don't worry
your own water you both cannot go
have dry throats in hell like for all i
care
that does not seem very did you get the
weight stems wayne
yeah i dropped them a whole bunch off
right here at the beginning there's a
team player thank you
and i've got a present for mine i am no
longer part
of your group i am playing on my own
in my own little world i am going to
survive well
somebody's a grumpy pants don't get
watered before
two minutes i'm going to
not talk to you anymore i don't know
what mark's so upset about oh
there's water all around the base
like a lot of water mark how far away
are you
i'm far enough away that i don't have to
hear you guys
i'm feeling like you could definitely
hear us but oh
cloverhood mark you're discovering stuff
finally contributing
clover pancho look at this guy
nope not engaging not engaging
it's okay buddy oh [ __ ] i found a spider
not engaging
oh hey mark mm-hmm not engaging you are
engaging you are clearly talking in
response to us which is engaging
you're going to want 100 engaging why do
you have your own
workbench over here nah talking also did
you know there's a big poisonous spider
about three feet from you
well i guess 10 centimeters from you
mark watch out
i'm concerned for your well-being not
engaging
there's a big scary spider right there
[Music]
mark what will it take to bring you back
into the team i miss you
ah mark can i get a hand hmm
not engaging sorry i'm i'm on my own
i tried to help you and i got killed
yeah you described i asked you a
question
your loyal follower asked you a question
mm-hmm this is a trick
there's a trick it's not a trick i love
you and i want to know how you're doing
it's trick i was dead you're not dead
you're fine i was dead
i was dead i said past tense was i
believe
uh you got the water you requested so i
don't know what you're all hot about
yeah not engaging definitely feels like
he's engaging doesn't it wade
yeah he feels very combative right now i
don't know why he's starting on all this
drama okay
how are you doing mark i'm fine but i'm
not engaging
you can engage if you want nope don't
want to
we could be friends again no we were
apparently never friends to begin with
oh no i'm thirsty mark how did you so
bravely get your water earlier
well doesn't matter how it'll be stolen
away from you at the last moment
well but i have to try even if i will be
unjustly punished for my own efforts
look up then does that resonate with you
does that that feel bad
just look up then have you figured out a
way to harvest this uh spider web mark
no i actually have no idea i really
don't know but that's the only time i'm
engaging with you
now engagement is gone oh look i my
i got a water and it dropped on the
ground and then somehow wade drank it
mark i'm in exactly the same boat as you
hurts doesn't it it hurts it doesn't
feel good it doesn't it doesn't feel
good
it feels bad even you could say yeah it
feels bad it feels like
if someone apologized
maybe that there would be some more
engaging happening
i think i understand what he's upset
about mark i am very sorry that i saw
that
water before you oh i spider oh my god
wow that actually hurt a lot oh it's big
i'm dead now i'm down and the spider is
talking about where is it i will save
you
but wait did you stay out of my way i
would make an apology for the amount of
damage mark did to me though
no no i think he i think he deserved
that and i think you deserve that
oh so we're even mark please revive me
we're coming we are trying but you're
very far away yeah well i was going
towards the exclamation point
like a good boy well i found that
earlier anyway it was a lab and then i
didn't go into it because i was waiting
for my friends
oh well i am your friend mark and i
apologize on wade's behalf for being
i am your friend i'm dead now respawn
swap team
quit super quit all right mark i'm
boo i i'm trying
sorry i took the water
all right apology accepted
whoa it didn't feel very good yeah well
it felt good for me
oh god oh my god i'm stuck
not messing around oh that spider's fast
one bait him away from my backpack and
away from me why
why wait i didn't know you were right
there or your backpack i didn't just
keep it true okay he's feasting on my
corn that's what it does
i will save you wade we are now best
friends god
get way up i'm about to go down i'm
getting him up
where's my last bastard
i don't even have my stuff back yet it's
just mercilessly chasing me
all right all right mark it's on you i'm
going to get away you want to get
weighed
i'll block it just run go bait it and
then go at 90 degrees when it strikes
wow
um it's looking maybe it won't notice
it or split it up idiot i'll go right
oh i'm stuck i'm stuck
okay we're spread out uh hey what you
taught me
hey i will go for a wait get wait i'm
going wait it's least you sleep
i lied okay you taught me it's on me
it's on me going good going and got him
i'll change it i'm down all right go for
bob
this seems familiar hmm this uh yeah
maybe we should
leave this area i don't know he's not
he's not
off me yet he's just watching me okay
going
runway run [ __ ] right we should get out
of here wait run
wait
[Music]
you